[Music]
come on
wow
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon
nice to see a lot of students here very
young kids very inspiring
you know the entire story
started
with a lot of children who were inspired
who were inspired to do so well in their
life
every child has a dream to grow a dream
to do well in their life and you know go
into excellent careers i think that's
the foundation vision for sri chaitanya
where my parents dr bias and dr jayanthi
garu has started this institution
and in india competitive exam
environment is not easy i think every
one of you know that especially for iats
nits and medical schools it's a very
tough challenging exam
so in order to prepare students for that
we have taken the approach of starting
very early on so that we can identify
areas of growth for students and make
sure they are able to rectify
their weaknesses and fight towards the
end for the competitive exam
and score is one of these exams now
you know we are
able to conduct this exam throughout the
country with the hope that students if
they identify these small aspects where
they are missing when they take a test
early on they will be able to rectify
those much quicker faster and more
efficiently before they get to 11th and
12th grades when they have to take the
competitive exams
so we are a very target driven
organization focused on results and of
course for younger grades all around
development as well that will give the
student the confidence to
excel in any competitive exam in their
careers respective careers
so how are we able to do that
right along with the team
uh you know the academics play a huge
role in guiding the student
understanding how to make the student
sharper more creative more application
oriented these are the important aspects
of any competitive exam and score will
be the foundation in the future
for students to identify themselves
as one of the players in that large
competition
it will give them the confidence that
yes i have done well or i am at sixty
percent or seventy percent or eighty
percent and i can aspire to grow another
twenty uh another twenty percent in the
next two to three years
it gives an immense opportunity for
every child to do so and this is one of
our endeavors and one of our efforts to
ensure that we help more number of kids
around the country do better for
themselves without any financial
constraints we are willing to support
all these children and today
based on last year's core exam we are
giving scholarship prizes to 30 students
and that is just the prizes and there
are thousands of kids who have secured
scholarships based on the last year's
core exam and this year as well we are
committed to give thousand crore worth
of scholarships to the kids who take the
score exam in 22-23
we've been lucky last year we've been
fortunate that five lakh students have
participated in score i think it helped
i think
from different states not just from
andhra telangana or south india from
kashmir we had hundreds of students who
have taken the score exam last year so
similarly in from different states and
this year our aspiration is to reach out
to thousand cities ten thousand schools
and one million participants in school
[Applause]
now along with suicide now we have
infinity learn our online education
platform through which we want to reach
millions of students who do not have
access to our branches close by
suicide has always been treated as a
neighborhood branch because andra
telangana karnataka where we are at we
are there everywhere i think all parents
know that and we want to become that way
in the other states as well so every
student should have the opportunity to
learn and succeed in life
and our competitive exam environment not
just gives student one or two options
but it gives multiple options in
multiple good universities in the
country
and india is growing very fast and times
are changing very quickly so let's get
our children ready for the next
generation and the next century
thank you
it's nice to see
our senior team here
and also our young children
it's very nice to see you all sri
chaitanya is always known for its
scholarships
it's known for having the scholarship
exam over several years but the
difference over last year and this year
had been that
until the year before we were only
confined to most of the physical
locations we were present we were not
able to go to other locations but with
help of infinity learn since last year
we were able to reach each and every
corner of india
from every corner any student will be
able to attend this exam
and will be able to avail the benefits
of the exam
like ms sushma was saying
this is not only about merit students
merit students is only a part of this
examination this is also about
financially backward students
and over years we've helped lacks of
them
and we've also had several instances
where
financially backward families approached
us
whether it be auto rickshaw drivers or
anybody else and they their kids did
very well and a lot of them went to iits
and medical schools as well
so we take pride in helping as many
students as we can
so i hope everybody uh takes this exam
everybody can
gain out of this
we've helped
fulfill crores of parents dream so far
and we are hoping to do much more going
forward thank you my job is very simple
to share how is scored better than last
year or last few years there are three
things which is which is largely
bigger and better in score this year
one website because of kovid for last
two years we could not do score offline
so this year score will be available in
all the 750 odd schools where
uh children can go and take tests on a
scheduled date and time
second our association with times of
india i think that makes it bigger and
better
this year we tied up with times of india
to have a larger access of score for
millions of students in different parts
of the country
we will be
going to almost 4 000 schools along with
them
we will
will expect
minimum almost three lakh students to
come through times of india relationship
to come to this uh take this core exam
we'll also
ensure that
uh with the help of times of india we
can make it reach to the
almost every household
for them to know that
if there's a student
either for merit
or for economic reason
scholarship is available
and i think that makes score very very
big and better this year
i think one more thing which which is
also
helping us a lot that with this platform
available this time score is
very different in nature so what we are
trying to do is to say that you know
students go to school sometimes somebody
has a coaching or somebody is going for
a tuition class at a given point of time
it's very difficult to come on a single
time to take the test
and what we have done after talking to
hundreds of students who have taken
school last year is to say that anytime
from morning 10 o'clock to evening seven
o'clock you can come and take the test
i think that gives a huge opportunity to
a lot of learners who who cannot take
the test on a scheduled time or a
specific time zone and this is only
available for the
internet or the platform platform-based
assessment
as far as offline assessment is
concerned there's a scheduled date and
time when they have to come to their
school to take the test
[Music]
you know this year's score is very very
different on multiple aspects now let me
take you through a demo of how score is
different this year let's show you some
of the very interesting features for
score this year uh can you go
up a little
uh how this score stem challenge this
year is uh until last year we were only
doing score uh this year we are calling
a score stem challenge uh stem is the
science technology engineering and
medicine and because of that our focus
is largely coming a lot more on stem
challenge this year from round two
onwards can we go a little further up so
if you see round one is a lot more about
score test
as we move further round two
three and four a lot more about stem
challenges there are there are some
audio visual challenges there are some
writing challenges and that takes makes
the score very different this year it is
not only about your subject matter
knowledge but it is also about your
aptitude your ability to speak your
ability to communicate in various forms
i think that makes score and then final
national level scores will flow so score
will first happen at a national level
basis the science and math largely or
the aptitude then move on further
testing students on stem challenges from
zones reason and finally coming back to
national level on overall uh making a
score stem challenge together and that's
where i think somewhere around february
mid we will again meet with all the
brilliant military students whom we have
identified over the last four months
uh
what is most important here is that
score test which is online the first
test is starting on 5th of september and
it will continue till 30th of november
so please
come over and
start your test on 5th of september uh i
think that's that's the day which is the
teachers day as well and this is the
best way you can give your guru dakshina
to the teacher by scoring the best boss
scoring a great scholarship you will
make your parents proud you'll make your
teachers proud
if you see
a score starts from grade one this year
i think that's the big debate which we
did uh we purposefully thought that why
should we leave the grade one and two
students if they have the merit and if
they have the zeal and entity to compete
give them an opportunity
so this is this is what scored this year
uh
we have tied up with times of india so
let me start with a demo we'll say let's
do for the first registration or score
today from this forum
can we start the registration please
so if you're coming to register you have
to put in your phone number to start
with
get it otp verified
thank you so much for verifying the otp
there's a small form
where
your name is there which grade you are
coming from
what are the grade you're selecting
your parents email id will be very handy
for us to keep the communication going
and you will see why it is which is
critical when we start getting into
solicitation uh we have to reach out to
parents talk to them and let you know
how your child is doing so
you you just fill your email id select
the grade go to the next step
and this is this time when you select
your because you selected 10th grade it
shows you a neet or je so select
what is your target exam do you want to
be a doctor or do you want to be an
engineer
this is that you select your neet and j
and then you select your state pin code
comes automatically you can see can you
just hold on for a second here
you see this you can a lot of school
names here if you find your school name
gray if you don't select others you have
a mode of exam as online
and
with this means then you can just
register now and you can come and take a
test
from fifth of september onwards any
point of time morning ten o'clock till
seven o'clock the test will be open
if this is an online you can take test
any of the days and between ten o'clock
to seven o'clock
and on your own preference of time
that's how you register for an online
examination
well if you want to go to take the
offline examination i will show you how
you can select an offline examination
but offline examination is not available
in all the cities it is only available
where we have a chat in a school or a
junior college or one of our knowledge
hub or a center where we provide j and
need training
so for example we'll select chandigarh
city
please go next process remains the same
you select meet or j select the
state or union territory and select by
exam city and then you can put your
school name here but if you see at the
bottom the mood of examination is
offline once you select offline it will
ask you a few questions so can we go
ahead and say book my slot
and it asks me see chaitanya center it
provides you an address and then you go
ahead and select a date say 16th october
10 o'clock to 11 30 is your
scheduled time you can pay here and
block the seat for taking the
examination
[Music]
good afternoon all of you
first of all i would like to
congratulate
all the people
who are involved
in conducting the score
last year
and for a huge number of
students taking the test that is
0.5 million that's a 5 lakhs
by looking at the numbers i would like
to keep a task
to all the
sri chaitanya
that in a couple of years
we should enroll at least 2 millions
2 millions
in the score
when it comes to
the career deciding examinations like
neet
and
this iit-jee mains an advance
wherein
students
that means
lots of students
from
tens of thousands of schools
will be taking the test so in that big
test
as it is the carrier deciding test
then the student must know
where
he stands
in the relative position along with
their competitors along with all other
students of that particular stream
so for that purpose
means to enable
their goal that sri chaitanya it is an
organization
which is producing
the top 10 top 100 and the top 1000
ranks in both the mains advanced and
neet consistently
consistently
and not only that
pushing
the lakhs of students into the
professional colleges across the country
maybe good the topmost medical colleges
and engineering colleges like iits
so that organization is providing an
opportunity to all the students
to know
their relative position
along with
some lakhs of students thank you very
much
a very good morning to all the
dignitaries
first of all
i'm very much happy to hear this quote
stem challenge
it's a wings given to all the students
in this india
so to fly
to reach their dreams in a successful
path
there are so many students
who are best in their knowledge and
skills
but financially they are very weak
so i feel
wherever we go north east west or south
where there is education
there we can find a banner called sri
chaitanya i proudly say about it
so
it may be instagram facebook or twitter
or whatever the network it may be so
here we can find only one word where
there is education that is so sri
shaitan educational institution so as we
have gone along with infinity learn as
well as co-test examination this co-test
is really
it's giving wings to all the students to
reach their goals so initially we can
find
we know that an ancient era says that so
for every 30 years a torch bearer is in
front of
anything to create a new destiny so here
it is the target bearer what i feel for
the students to reach their goals
so
i wish all the best to all the team and
it's all our responsibility to take this
courtesy examination for the students to
reach their goals thank you very much
so the main motto of this score stem
challenge scholarship exam is
there are so many raw diamonds
across the india
so we have to identify those diamonds
and give polish to them and
shine like kohinoor diamonds that is our
motto so through this score stem
challenge examination we want to make
world-class leaders for the coming
decade
so
previously we have seen so many
students from india
rose up to the higher level and ruling
different companies across the world
mainly
the score exam purposes
the student get benefits in three ways
they get access to
quality education and second one through
our program definitely student can focus
on their actual goals and third one
our
environment is
such we give such environment that every
student
feels it like a home and they feel more
comfortable and
from morning to evening our support will
be there throughout their education life
so thank you for giving me this
opportunity
thank you
honorable directors
sri chaitanya institutions
administrators
present in this event
and agms
my senior
people
and parents
and dear students good afternoon
everybody
i'm very happy to be here
on this wonderful occasion
of launching stores score stem challenge
today
let me congratulate
the management
as well as each and every person
so we are all giving an opportunity to
acquire
the opportunity to millions of students
to acquire wonderful knowledge
so
lacks of parents and students
thousands of campuses
thank you all i wish
sritanya a great success ahead
and definitely
we all feel proud to be with sri
caitanya forever thank you thank you all
good afternoon all the dignities
i would like to thank
to be here to explain about our
curriculum
yeah
before that actually here i would like
to
congratulate all the team
members actually to make the grand
success of the score exam last year then
we got the best students
to produce the result
and sri chaitanya always thinks for the
future generation
to give the best always one step before
what the parents thinks
then we would like to
fulfill the students and parents desires
and goals
and always teach chaitanya prepares the
curriculum
according to the
new generation then our curriculum
really helps the students
to reach their goals
once again here congratulates you
chaitanya
team members and initially learned team
members
to make the last year the score exam
grand success this year also we make the
grand success with the good number
with millions people are giving actually
one or two but here just no limit it's
infinity
thank you thank you very much for giving
this opportunity very good afternoon all
the dignitaries
i
congratulate all the students
who scored who are in top position in
the last year score examination so thank
you so much for giving me this
opportunity thank you once again
[Music]
dania's scorecam talent exam is one of
the most prestigious exam
which enables and enhances the inner
potential of the student academic
caliber to crack the iit and the neet
exams score is very useful to know the
strong and weak areas of the particular
student in their respective subjects on
their topics and sub topics
score will give the crystal clear
analysis of the students about their
subjects about their topics and sub
topics it helps to emerge the students
in the right from the foundation level
and the students knowledge can be
enhanced
and cleansed to the higher level it's a
wonderful effort from the protagonists
of prestigious richaitanya
by participating in this test the
students will have the opportunity to
test themselves as to how strong they
are in objective mode of learning and
testing i wish everyone involved in this
uh jagan decommission all the very best
shree jaidena is always stands asia's
number one for its foresightedness
determination and leadership now it's
time to turn around and have a glance on
its own blemishes journey with score
once again score is at your doorstep to
color your dreams all the best dear
students assess your knowledge with this
great challenge sri chaitanyas the score
step recheck your core concepts reinvent
your strategies re-energize your goals
re-infuse your self-confidence reward
your efforts enroll now wish you all the
best for your great future sco
sri chaitanya outstanding achiever
reward examination is one of india's
most prominent promising scholarship
from talent such examinations
it is a platform for students seeking a
strong academic foundation thank you sri
chaitanya sports stem challenge is one
of the most prestigious exam for school
students two ss who have high academic
talent and exceptional intellectual
ability to crack neet and je score stem
improves your confidence resilience and
self-esteem
it's a great platform to demonstrate
your abilities and knowledge amongst an
unknown and larger prayer group
the challenge will
improve your attainment and achievement
so dear students attempt this challenge
and get yourself awarded in the esteemed
organization of sri chaitanya all the
best the future belongs to the students
who believe in their dreams
and sri chaitanya is here to take care
of your dream future with its school
stem challenge school stem challenge
invites students to strategize
and build solutions to problems using
science technology engineering
mathematics skills
then why wait
take up sri chaitanya's core stem
challenge and fulfill your dreams and
aspirations by laying a strong
foundation for the career of your choice
[Music]
so
come on
[Music]
good evening one and all present here my
name is niriksha i'm studying in grade 4
i'm studying in sri chaitanya techno
school pina branch today i want to talk
about infinity learn
infinity learn is education where we
have fun exams and writing and reading
it's very fun to learn over here and i'm
proud to be a student in 40 students
over all over india
and i hope
infinity learn will help me forward be
going on like this and my hobbies to
become an army army doctor
and allowed to save army lives and i
allowed to india become and developed
country as soon as possible and sri
chaitanya faculties helped me as
clearing the doubts
as
as if we want and making activities as
fun
and
repeating the questions multiple times
and making students to understand thank
you i am starting at infinity learn
infutiliar is an amazing platform for
need and je aspiring students who are
early starters like me and the best
thing about this platform is that they
have a separate app for
doubt solving which really helped me a
lot to solve my doubt at a specific
subject
as i'm from tamil nadu i cannot i cannot
access
the schools which are not near me so
this online platform helps and helps
people who who can't access physical
education from chaitanya schools
and not only that the free materials
they provide is also worthy to read
as because of this this has made a great
impact on my academics so i thank
infinity learned for strengthening my
weekend areas good evening
so my perspective is
when i look at my son so he has a dream
and i need to help him
to achieve the dream now if i see the
you know the competitive exam in india
now it is one of the toughest examples
so things should not come from your
brain rather from your memory respond
your muscles so muscle memory is very
very important
now if i see the you know chaitanya and
the infinity so they are very perfect
blending between the knowledge
assimilation
and the speed what you need in the exam
and
when i you know looked at their teaching
methodology now so i'm very happy that
you know my son is doing the right job
thank you thank you so much for
attending this conference please have a
good evening
[Music]